so have you heard because i know that
your character from parks rec you were
talking about earlier um has inspired a
lot of people that a library was
nominated for a leslie knope award have
you heard about this
like it's one of those things it's kind
of funny because it's like funny like
from the show but it's also really cool
very cool yeah i mean if anyone watches
the show they'll know that um
we hate libraries
it's funny but like it's inspiring and
i'm glad the library thinks they're so
great
but you're not we had a really funny
thing in the show where the parks and
rec department just like the library was
always our problem which really made us
laugh my parents were public school
teachers
library is a big deal growing up you
have to support our library so it's how
fantastic so cool yeah
sam we actually would you like to say hi
we've been talking to ohio and they
actually have one of the this is leanne
the librarian who is actually nominated
and she's a big fan
hi
oh right here
he's a librarian at the bexley public
library right yes that's correct yes uh
we were nominated for a nope award which
of course is so exciting um one of our
patrons nominated us and librarians we
make up probably the entire fandom of
parks and rec so it's pretty awesome
yeah we're really excited now leanne is
your mom disappointed that you turned
out to be a librarian
uh yeah you know what actually i have a
background in art history so being a
librarian was the better option
[Applause]
that's amazing well leah do you want to
say anything to amy i know you're a fan
oh yeah we have a big bone to pick with
leslie knope about um her opinion about
libraries
but no for real this is crazy because i
actually have a picture of leslie knope
on my desk at work so it's really crazy
to see you in person and thank you so
much for all of the support for
libraries and for local governments
thank you so much
wait so you made amy poehler is it is it
correct that like it was a paddle out of
doors and it was doors from the parks
and rec set right
yeah how did you do that when the show
finished uh the the entire bullpen of
that great set for parks and rec uh all
the trim was red oak that actually had
come from indiana to california i know
but they let you have it well no here's
the thing so
oh and this this is this is a real beef
i have with the the corporate side of
our business is that because of
liability you're not supposed to take
anything out of the dumpster like wood
like like it's wasteful it's super
wasteful
so i mentioned when they struck the set
for parks and rec i said to the guy
driving the truck to the landfill
if you happen to hit a speed bump near
my shop and some of this red oak falls
onto the sidewalk
i would love to turn it into canoe
paddles to give to the cast and the
producers which is so cool so yeah i
mean
i'm
i'm grateful
that that driver was somewhat reckless
uh
yeah in the book you revealed that you
and your wife both have a connection to
rob lowe and i know that connection but
everyone else doesn't so explain
well uh
you know when you get together with
another actor and this is true and this
is my whole life when you start dating
someone one of the things you do
you have an awareness of like oh by the
way
i was in a play with this person or you
like you figure out who you've both
kissed or like you know
you sort of this is a conversation yeah
it's it's a thing
so that you you know i mean it's true of
of any new relationship where it's not
me i don't want to know any past but you
learn it but eventually you learn about
each other's significant others okay and
in this case because he's a marquee name
it came up at some point that megan in
the movie about last night had had this
crazy
throat kissing scene with rob lowe where
she plays this this floozy like trying
to
distract him from demi moore yeah and
they have this crazy french kissing
scene and at some point i randomly saw
it
we were at a hotel and it happened to be
on tv and i it was so traumatic where i
was like and what are you doing i mean
it was 15 years later but i said
honey you clearly are in love with rob
lowe
this is going to be a situation between
us and and so it was all it always kind
of stuck with me but then
until some years later on parks and
recreation in an episode where i think
rob lowe's character finds out that it's
ron swanson's birthday and he ends up
kissing me on the mouth in this episode
both been there at which point i was
like okay honey i get it uh
it's everything's cool everything's fine
and not only i mean if
if you step back a little ways and
squint you you could say that we've had
a threesome
[Laughter]
that's how it is that's what your book
should have been called
arthurism with roblox
that's amazing i love that i don't know
if i'd want to know all that no i mean i
think i just not that it bothers me i
just mean like you can't help your path
so why talk about it it is weird and and
especially if your if your wife is a
gorgeous you know star
they they keep coming out where you'll
be watching a show
and she'll be like oh actually i uh
i was engaged to this guy uh
you know and you're like oh my god
and you're like that's fine that's fine
honey that's amazing so in parks and rec
you got to meet joe biden right because
i got to meet him he was so nice
so what was your experience like it was
great he came on he was had a role on
the show like he was obviously playing
himself but
he was so good and such a pro like
really good on camera knew his lines uh
and then we did another episode where he
and dr biden were both on the first lady
were both on
and uh and they were the best yeah
they're very sweet yeah like behind the
scenes that's what i thought was the
coolest like she was asking me about
like
just life like kids like normal stuff
and i was like oh okay you're like being
normal okay yeah and not that you're not
normal yeah and he's like
adam how are you and like
like shake your hand and you're like oh
okay there's like this magic thing here
where you're making me feel like i'm the
most important person in the world i
know and then you like start divulging
stuff yeah actually
you're like yeah can i tell you about
something that happened to me when i was
my child
he's like no i'm not actually injured my
mom let me go see the grateful dead and
that's right
tomorrow is valentine's day yeah do you
celebrate valentine's day are you kind
of like well let's not forget about
galentine's day
so valentine's day for those of you that
that don't know is um the writers of
parks and rec created this kind of fake
holiday where leslie knope the character
i played on the show would go out with
her her gals her friends and celebrate
so i celebrate valentine's day all the
time and in fact i'm spending
valentine's day with rashida jones and
aubrey plaza and catherine hahn we're
having dinner tonight that's awesome
wow
um
i celebrated galentine's dance when i
was like 30.
i mean for real so i'm very aware and if
you're gay then every valentine's day is
valentine's day exactly
women are a good time for sure gay or
not it's a fun time it's a fun time i
think that i think it's fun to make up
your own holidays yes right and we
should yeah and i just think you need to
start making cards then you can profit
off of this great idea you're so right
a lot of money i'm leaving on the table
you are just giving it away
but did you ever have to do i remember
in school i always we had to do like the
valentine's day things either you did
carnations we did incarnations you had
to write who you wanted to give a
carnation to and then
like a kid would show up at your
classroom with a with a box of
carnations and kind of call out
everyone's name yeah she's just so
horrible right which is because i never
got one did you were you that kid like i
really wasn't at all there were so many
of us there'd literally be like five
people that got him and it would be like
well i guess it wasn't my turn like it
was like
all those people
yeah all those people that got them kind
of peaked too early and it's been a
tough go for them ever
since he peaked in high school i wanna
peak in high school
but it also is and it's not an awful
thing too because then you'd find out
like it was actually just like a
girlfriend that sent it to her
girlfriend so she didn't feel lame yeah
i'm like that doesn't count cheater yeah
yeah i feel like nowadays people you
know like schools don't really pressure
you as much as they did when i was
growing up in the 80s it was a lot of
like who are you going to marry who's
your boyfriend you're like i'm in third
grade yeah
that's in the south they do that all the
time it's like every time at a holiday
it's like amy's your boyfriend i'm like
why can't i just be me like i didn't
bring anyone because i'm in second grade
but um
yeah they push you in the south for some
reason they do it in boston too oh
speaking of your show that i love boston
i really do
i that's not even a part of our
conversation but i it's one of my
favorite places to tour because y'all
are like texans with sports it is like
y'all are so hardcore yeah it is awesome
i was there when y'all broke the 80
whatever your streak or whatever i was
at that game i got to sing and i was
like literally
y'all are crazy wait i remember this
because i was watching that game stephen
tyler was there too it was like one of
the what are the world too but isn't
that thing that y'all ended up breaking
the streak and y'all you would have
thought we landed on mars yeah like
where we made it like we are hardcore
about yeah
so sports
[Music]
you